McElligott: Let's look at the sustainable seafood case.
And tell us what are the pieces
of that, and do they exist now?
Are they out there and deployed?
Do we have IOT (Internet of Things) in the seas?
That's validating these things?
What's the ecosystem if you will of technology?
How much of those things are in place, and
how much is almost there or a bit further off?
McElligott: Can you give us a sense?
Behlendorf: Sure, sure.
Behlendorf: I don't think it's a hardware problem.
Like I think there are devices now that are
available off-the-shelf to be able to do
the kinds of stuff I mentioned.
There's a company called Smart Catch
that makes these net sensors.
They even have video cameras on them. So you
can see the kind of fish that you caught.
It's kind of crazy. There are sensors on buoys
and at ports and things like that
to collect that data. That's real.
The blockchain side of that picture is really simple.
It's, you know, you stand up a network of nodes...
I mean this is why Hyperledger was built.
This stuff is in production now.
That ledger, that chain, is not in production yet. It's
still being developed. Intel is one of the leads on that.
But they have gone to a number of the different fish processors and some of the major fleet operators.
All of whom, what they're trying to prevent are the
renegade fishermen who actually
offload their catches to legit fishermen
in weird waters. Who then come back
into port and try to offload.
I'd say probably the biggest challenge will be getting
a critical mass of the participants in any marketplace.
At enough layers in the chain
from beginning to end
to start working together so that they basically shame...
by working well, shame the rest
into joining that network.
And maybe it means eventually, if you're not part
of the network, you can't sell your fish.
Not only to Whole Foods, but maybe not even
to any supply any retailer in the United States
So I think... there's a bootstrapping problem
with a lot of these things.
McElligott: So to look at it a little bit more closely...
It's starting with the fishing level... to the merchant level is the end point. Along the way there are
transportation legs that are there. There may be the
port itself that needs to have some infrastructure there.
And does it look like it would be something like
the "Good Housekeeping Seal" that this is like
certified... and again this isn't obviously your
piece of this, but I'm curious what you're hearing,
because you're talking to... in your role,
you're encountering every piece of the ecosystem
that are touching this stuff. Is it that
I would have an app and I would be able to see
that this fish... and verify it myself... or that the merchant is providing that certainty at that level?
Behlendorf: this is still predominantly
a business-to-business technology.
And it should be the case that
they'll be eventually providers who act as
a kind of a portal for average consumers.
So that in theory Whole Foods should be able
to provide you some sort of app that says
"Where did my fish come from?" that surface
the data back to that chain.
You still have to trust that Whole Foods is telling you the truth, right?
But it could be at some point that
that ledger becomes fully public
and there's multiple ways to get to it and verify it.
An example of an application I'd really like to see, that
looks more like that would be voter registration rolls.
So a lot of people talk about, "Hey, should we use
the blockchain to help manage elections?"
And I think it's a  terrible idea to cast votes
using a blockchain.
Because it's really hard to simultaneously preserve the
integrity of the election and the confidentiality of voters
while being able to audit it.
But you could use a distributed ledger for the voter registration side of it.
So that everyone's looking at the same database
with regards to who's registered to vote where.
And you could use it at the tail end, too. Which is what's
the summary from each of the different polling places.
And rolling that up to a state level
or national summary for how the vote went.
And in both those cases having the
public be able to see that ledger, each
individual item, the entire spreadsheet so to speak,
is essential to building trust
and confidence in the process.
So for that I would fight
for that to be very public.
For something like diamonds, the participants in
that market have already gone through this complex,
political balancing act of sharing just enough
information that they can audit each other
on where these diamonds came from.
But not sharing things like the prices they paid, right?
And other metadata that could be used by investors
perhaps to short stocks of companies that
they think might not be doing well.
I'm a very pro "open data" kind of guy,
and transparency kind of guy.
But for a lot of good reasons,
the business communities
are only willing to share data if it means
they can't get access to other things.
And in the case of the diamond industry there was
a mandate from the policymakers
to clean up their act when it came to
blood diamonds and that sort of thing.
And that kind of pressure is essential
in a lot of these chains.
I think these chains are a way to finally get things
that economists consider externalities in markets.
finally reintegrated into the flow
of goods and commerce.
Whether that's labor conditions
or carbon load, for example,
of the different products flowing through.
Or other things correlating to
the sustainable development goals.
So that's the idealist in me,
and that's why I'm involved in this.
You've got to create just enough
economic value, business value,
for the businesses to pick it up and use it.
Because they won't do that just endogenously.
They need some business problem
that they can solve at the same time.